Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today Rick Doblin, who's the founder
and executive director of MAPS, the Multidisciplinary
Association for Psychedelic Studies, which
researches legal developing legal contexts
for the careful and beneficial uses of psychedelics
and marijuana.
Rick, it's great to have you back on today.
Speaker 4: Yes, it's my pleasure.
I look forward to our discussion, so
Speaker 1: I want to eventually get to what
some of the advancements and developments
have been since you and I last spoke a couple
of years ago.
But first, you mentioned that you were recently
in Texas with a bunch of Republicans, including
Dan Crenshaw, who is not known typically as
the progressive beacon of hope to the left.
But there seem to be some sort of camaraderie
on the issue of using psychedelics for for
veterans and in other contexts.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, Representative Crenshaw
is a former Navy SEAL, right, and he's heard
now from quite a number of Navy SEALs who
have PTSD, traumatic brain injury, and the
treatments that they've been getting from
the VA haven't been helping them.
And so there's a group called Vets by Amber
and Marcus Kapone that brings particularly
Navy SEALs down to Mexico for ibogaine, which
is a psychedelic drug from Western Africa,
and also five MDMA, which is a drug from the
Sonoran toad.
It's the most powerful of all the psychedelics.
And these Navy SEALs have been finding a lot
of relief and other veterans as well.
And so they've been sharing the news with
Dan Crenshaw.
And also he's been hearing with some of the
veterans and others in our studies with MDMA
for PTSD.
And so now he has become a major advocate
and he's working of all bipartisan way with.
Tim Ryan, who is the congressman from Ohio,
friend of the show.
Speaker 1: Very good guy.
Speaker 4: Yeah, he's fantastic.
So that the two of them, though, are working
together.
We're getting ready to launch a bill to give
twenty five million to the Department of Defense
for psychedelic research for PTSD.
And then another bill to give twenty five
million to the VA.
And so what we're finding is that the healing
of veterans and others with trauma from trauma
is bipartisan.
And one of the things that was so interesting
at the discussion with Dan Crenshaw is here.
I am surrounded by Texas Republicans and I
talked about how maps as a nonprofit, we've
raised over one hundred and fifteen million
dollars in donations to do this research.
Over our thirty five years and I started out
by saying that we've got this bipartisan support
and I talked about Rebecca Mercer, who was
the family big supporters of Trump and Bannon
owned Cambridge Analytica.
We know about scraping all the data from Facebook.
I said we have support from Rebecca Mercer,
from Elizabeth Koch, whose father is Charles
Koch, and we have support from the Rockefeller
family, the Buffett family, the Pritzker was.
And I said and goes all the way to George
Soros, who also supports us.
And there was kind of this sort of initial
kind of joke or groan that Dan Cranshaw made
about George Soros.
But in the end, it was like it was like we're
all in it together.
That was the dominant message.
There was one thing that was really surprising
to me, too, which was afterwards there was
a woman who's a therapist, used to be a therapist
at the Houston VA, and she does what's called
MDR, which is an approach towards helping
people with PTSD.
And we talked about her husband was a veteran
and she's helped him with PTSD.
She's very interested in our research.
And then she said she's actually running for
Congress.
I said, that's really good.
And then she said, yeah, I'm running against
a Republican.
I said, all right.
So we talked.
It was like we exchanged cards.
It was very interesting.
And then I get home to write her a little
email and I discover that she's running as
a Republican against a Republican who's not
sufficiently right wing.
She's right.
Currently existing
Speaker 1: Republican.
But she likes what you're doing.
Speaker 4: She likes what we're doing because
she likes healing veterans.
So somehow or other able to take psychedelics
and healing of trauma and move it out of this
partizan struggle.
And it seems like it's going pretty well in
that way.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's it's an incredible thing.
And I mean, I would be curious to hear, since
we last talked, there were so many things
you were researching.
There were so many things that you were studying.
What are the sort of tangible advancements
that have been made in this field of using
psychedelics and as well as sometimes cannabis
for for a lot of different situations, wellbeing,
et cetera?
What advancements have we made in the last
couple of years?
Speaker 4: Well, in May, we published We Meaning
Maps that we published the results from our
first Phase three study of MDMA assisted psychotherapy
for PTSD.
You have to do two phase three studies to
get a drug approved by FDA and they have to
prove safety and efficacy.
And the first study was published in Nature
Medicine, which is one of the most highest
impact scientific journals in the world.
And we had outstanding results better than
we even had hoped.
And so what we showed it was highly significant
results, statistically significant, large
effect size, excellent safety record.
The most amazing part is we work with the
hardest cases, meaning severe PTSD, chronic
PTSD.
Unlike many PTSD studies, we enroll people
who have previously attempted suicide.
And what we showed is that two months after
the last experimental session, two thirds
of these people no longer had PTSD.
It's just astounding.
The control group was thirty two percent.
That's the group that got therapy without
MDMA.
So 30 to almost one third no longer had PTSD
from our therapy.
But when you add MDMA to the therapy, it's
sixty seven percent no longer have PTSD.
And of the one third that still has PTSD,
most of them had what's called clinically
significant reductions of PTSD symptoms.
So we are the only group that's in phase three
with psychedelics.
There's now about one hundred plus psychedelic
companies, for profit companies, a few nonprofits,
and they're either in earlier stages of the
research or they're trying to develop new
molecules that they can patent new psychedelics.
But we're the only ones in phase three.
So that's the main development.
There's also groups that have been working
with psilocybin and they're doing well in
phase two.
And it's psilocybin for depression, psilocybin
for nicotine addiction, psilocybin for alcoholism,
psilocybin for obsessive compulsive disorder.
We've also completed studies with psilocybin
excuse me, with MDMA for social anxiety, for
people anxious about life threatening illnesses.
There was an incredible study done by others
that we helped with David not and then says
in England, MDMA for alcohol use disorder.
What it turns out is that trauma is what drives
a lot of drug addiction.
If you help people deal with the traumas of
life, then they don't need to run away and
drugs.
And so we were able to show good results in
that.
There's also starting to be interesting, promising
findings with traumatic brain injury that
certain psychedelics can be helpful.
With that, there's just a whole range of studies
that are now being started with psychedelics
that are really showing enormous progress.
And one of the main things that we know is
that psychedelics promote what's called neuroplasticity.
And what that means is that our brains are
not fixed.
They evolve as we grow.
We know that when we remember things, there's
something changed in our brain.
But more importantly, psychedelics can promote
new neural connections in different kind of
pathways.
So for PTSD, there's been neuroscientists
at Johns Hopkins School Dublin who did work
with MDMA, giving them to octopuses and giving
MDMA to mice for the octopuses.
They're very solitary creatures and they stay
away from other octopuses unless it's mating
season, which is the end of their life.
But you give them MDMA and now they want to
hang out with other octopuses.
And so these kind of preverbal deep in our
evolutionary history, MDMA has this profound
impact.
But in mice, when you give MDMA to mice, it
promotes oxytocin release, which is the hormone
of love.
They call it the cuddle hormone, the love
nursing mothers.
And it promotes new neural connections, new
growth of of neurons in new pathways.
Do you agree in what happens
Speaker 1: in these studies when the studies
with people is there like a placebo group,
where do people know whether they're getting
the MDMA or not?
Because that seems like it would be a relevant
question in terms of measuring the impact.
Right.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's a great question,
my dissertation at the Kennedy School of Government,
where I got my master's and PhD, was on the
regulation of the medical use of psychedelics.
And one of the main things I looked at was
how do you do a double blind study with a
drug like a psychedelic?
That's pretty obvious.
If you've taken it like you're taking different
pills and you don't notice automatically what
they do.
These are very powerful drugs that change
your consciousness and you usually can tell
if that's happened.
Sure.
So a lot of my dissertation was about how
to solve this problem.
And I thought I had the solution.
The solution, I thought was going to be therapy
with low dose MDMA versus therapy with full
dose MDMA.
And the challenge was to find the dose of
MDMA that was high enough that enough people
would notice it and would not be certain.
Was it the low dose or the high dose, but
that it wasn't so high that you started getting
all the therapeutic potentials of MDMA?
And this is what we explored in phase two.
So maps I started in nineteen eighty six.
We started our first phase one safety study,
nineteen ninety two and in nineteen ninety
nine in 2000 we started the phase two studies
and that took us till twenty sixteen.
But what we discovered and this is I guess
you could say, the beauty and humility of
scientific research is that you discover stuff
that you didn't realize was actually going
on or you discover that you were wrong.
So what I discovered through these studies
and we tested inactive placebo with therapy.
Twenty five milligrams, 30 milligrams, 40
milligrams, 50 milligrams.
Seventy five milligrams, one hundred one twenty
five and one fifty.
And what we showed is that the therapeutic
dose was lower than we thought.
Seventy five milligrams was very effective,
but that the lower doses.
They did cause a certain amount of inaccurate
guesses, but what they did is they had an
anti therapeutic effect, meaning that everybody
still got better, who got these lower therapy
plus lower doses.
But when we looked at the data, the people
that had therapy without MDMA did better than
the people that had therapy with low dose
MDMA.
And the best way to describe it, it's like
if you're in an airplane and you're about
to take off, sometimes there's turbulence
at the beginning and then you get above the
clouds and then it's smooth sailing.
So the low doses of MDMA were like this turbulence.
They people were focused on their trauma.
They were activated a little bit.
But the fear reduction properties of MDMA
weren't fully activated, made people uncomfortable.
So when we went to the FDA to design phase
three, I open it up by saying that there's
a funny quote by a former president of Harvard.
And what he said was, never forget.
There's always a Harvard man on the wrong
side of every issue.
And so I said, in this case, it's me, my dissertation,
which fortunately I managed to get my theory
was wrong and that there is no solution to
the double-blind problem.
And so he said to the FDA, we can give you
the blinding, but you're going to make it
easier for us to find a difference between
the two groups.
And the real question is, if you can do this
work with therapy without adding a drug, why
add the drug?
So rather than adding a drug that gives a
little bit of blinding, it's more important
that we test the therapy by itself where it's
the most effective.
And so the FDA brought in what we like to
joke as the old wise man of the FDA.
His name is Bob Temple and he's been there
since nineteen seventy two.
And he was the Office of Science Policy and
he came and he said there is he agreed there
is no solution to the double-blind problem.
And he said that there are other ways to try
to reduce experimenter bias.
The double-blind is really to make it so that,
you know, you don't get biased results, that
you don't find what you want to find.
Right.
And so what they first have said is what's
called random assignment.
That means everybody is similarly motivated
and then they get randomized either to the
control group or the experimental group.
The other thing they said is that the independent
raters who evaluate the outcomes that you
can't have, the therapists say, oh, did this
person get better or not?
Or even the person themselves to to do that,
you need independent raters.
And this is done through an hour long interview
with the patient about all of their symptoms.
And so we have these independent raters and
a very robust system.
We have over 20 of them trained by the Boston
Veteran's Administration where they developed
the measure.
They do it by random assignment, meaning it's
all telemedicine.
So they don't know the patient where they
are in the treatment process.
They don't know if they've got MDMA or the
placebo.
So based on that, the FDA said that they would
agree with us that we would do therapy without
MDMA versus therapy with him.
Do you may even still, there's about 10 percent
of the people that are confused about what
they got, which is pretty astonishing.
But sometimes people that resist the emotional
effects of MDMA because they're so scared
of what's going on, they have kind of a muted
effect.
So there is a little bit of confusion.
But we also negotiated with the European Medicines
Agency.
We're trying to negotiate all over the world
to globalize MDMA therapy.
And so the European Medicines Agency went
through the same analysis and they also agreed
with the FDA that it's therapy without MDMA
versus therapy with MDMA and therapy with
inactive placebo.
And we're also doing research in Israel and
Canada.
We've done some in Brazil.
We're just moving forward into Australia.
So I think the frustrating part in a way,
is that there is no good solution to the double-blind
problem.
But the FDA realizes that that even though
the methodology doesn't work, people are still
suffering.
You still have to do the research and you
still have to design the studies as best you
can.
Right.
So the breakthrough that we had was our first
phase three study being tremendously successful.
And so we are now doing the second phase three
study.
We do have a site here in Boston.
And many of your listeners may have heard
of a book called The Body Keeps the Score.
It's by a fellow, Bessel van der Coke, who's
a psychiatrist here in Boston.
Amazingly, by the way, he published the book
six years ago about trauma.
And two weeks ago, it was the number one bestselling
book on the New York Times bestseller list
of print and e-book combinations.
So there's an enormous cultural interest now
in trauma.
And Bessel is the principal investigator of
our Boston site, and he thinks that MDMA is
the most effective thing he's seen for PTSD
in his entire career.
Yeah, so it's very much excited.
Speaker 1: It's incredible the advancements
that are being made.
And yeah, the body keeps the score a great.
A great book for anybody to read, regardless
of one situation, an important book, Rick,
always so glad to hear about the things that
are going on.
Speaker 4: Yes, please.
Just just that we think that the second phase
three study we will have completed in October
of twenty, twenty two and we think by the
end of twenty, twenty three, we expect to
have FDA approval and then we're training.
We want to train twenty five thousand therapists
and set up thousands of psychedelic clinics
throughout the United States and thousands
more throughout the world.
Speaker 1: Ambitious and fantastic.
Rick Doblin from from Maps.
Always so great speaking to you, Rick.
Speaker 4: Thank you for having me.
David.